today we check in with the fat community
over at Tick Tock a realm that we may
call thick talk that's actually my
producer Sean's joke now as the host of
the show it's my god-given right to
steal the joke without credit I can
steal any joke I hear around here
because it's mine that's the way it goes
but I decided to forego that privilege
and give credit where it's due in this
case so there it is Tick Tock anyway
we'll start with one recent viral video
from a fat activist and then perhaps
we'll continue down the thick talk
rabbit hole and see what else we may
find here it is
I'm gonna prove to you why white people
are the reason I'm fat today there's
just no way if white people didn't go
looking for spices then various sea
routes to Indian subcontinent and Africa
and other places of the world would not
get discovered and if they didn't get
discovered then East India Company would
never come to Indian subcontinent
and if they didn't come then the
fertility of the land would not get
destroyed because they forced us to
cultivate tobacco and dyes and opioid
things like that and that destroyed the
fertility nobody forced them your own
people decided to over cultivate the
land and sell it because it was
financially gainful for them and it
enriched your nation and what you put in
your [ __ ] mouth is your own [ __ ]
fault and problem as our friend Andrew
Tate would say right [ __ ] it out of here
guy what the [ __ ] I'm gonna listen to
this oh God here we go and then if that
didn't happen and if they didn't exploit
and extract resources until my ancestors
were left with nothing to eat we
wouldn't move to this grain heavy very
little nutritious diet that we have
today
also if white people didn't come to the
Indian subcontinent then the [ __ ]
door swings both ways pumpkin you don't
have to stay well you don't want to go
ahead go unpack your bags for you what
the oh I hate it here I hate it here I
hate it here everybody's so bad I love
how she acknowledges that there's that
there's knowledge that what she eats
isn't nutritional but she won't
acknowledge that she can just go and
find out what is nutritional I need it
she acts like what she was [ __ ]
taught to eat from her culture like she
can't eat anything else ancestors would
not go through 50. small medium large
famines in a period of 200 years okay
explain the famines like what what
happens did we charge Jordans and in
1943 nearly 3 million people would not
have died due to this starvation and
malnutrition where where and if that
didn't happen then this entire place
um and the people of this place would
not
adapt to survive on Lower calories
okay I didn't realize I was a 45 minute
clip uh but it's a fun game I have to
admit it's like it's like the
self-victimizing version of seven
degrees of Kevin Bacon just take some
negative aspect of yourself that you
don't want to take responsibility for
and then find a way to cast the blame as
far away from yourself as possible I can
do this too you know for instance I tend
to be impatient and at times
ill-tempered I admit it's not my fault
though it can actually be traced
directly back to Alexander the Great's
invasion of Persia in 334 BC I'll need
to do some research on Wikipedia to
connect all the dots but I'm sure
there's a way to do it that's such a
crazy thought that like she really
believes that it's not her fault that
she's fat I wonder like if you don't
think it's your fault that you're fat
you must think like everything and you
know why a lot of people also think that
they're fat is they're like oh I'm
depressed that's why I'm fat because
they've been told that like if you're
depressed that's all these excuses I can
tell you I'm depressed so I'm I'm just
[ __ ] that's why I'm fat yeah is that
crazy that some people genuinely think
like that the doctor hasn't figured out
yet the doctor hasn't I get that one a
lot like or some version of of it's the
doctor's fault I go I've gone to 10
doctors they can't figure it out I can
honestly say in my youth there were
times when I blamed my own [ __ ] on other
people and that's part of a you know a
learning curve as a human being is to be
able to get to a point where you take
full responsibility for your own stuff
unfortunately not everybody has people
in their Circle or in their family or in
their whatever around them to teach them
about personal responsibility and
clearly this girl doesn't she's either
surrounded by victims or surrounded by
people who are just ignoring her [ __ ]
the thing though is now we have so much
knowledge and so much available to us
that it is our responsibility those of
us that know I have grown into a person
who takes responsibility for my own [ __ ]
it's not easy you just say God damn it
why are you doing this stop it and and
make that shift from what I want where I
am to what I want but it is our
responsibility every you me everybody
listening to take everybody sorta under
our wing or at least well nobody even
you can to try to convince the people
that we are having personal interactions
with this is your fault and it's your
problem and nobody cares so you have to
fix it like because you're not a victim
you're the victim of your own [ __ ] and
that's what we have to really get out
there meanwhile there is as always an
obvious contradiction at work here on
the one hand we're told that fat is
beautiful fat is good fat is healthy fat
is desirable on the other hand it's also
very important for us to believe that
fat people are fat through no fault of
their own such Hypocrites the left
because everything that they say is good
then they go and like they go and roast
people for it like they're so Pro lgbtq
and then when they get interviewed about
Andrew Tate they're like yeah he's a
closeted gay they always they're like
yeah yeah I think he's secretly gay like
what do you mean by that yeah they
always say that I've actually heard that
but I've heard that a lot that's not
just a one-time thing I hear that
consistently am I tripping like you guys
can say in the chat you've heard that a
lot right where like literal leftist BLM
social activists that they call people
like closeted gays and stuff so weird
this is good but it's not my fault well
if it's beautiful and good then why
would you not want to take credit for it
in fact if white people made this girl
fat then shouldn't she be thanking us
given that fat is beautiful We Made You
Beautiful you're welcome which is it is
my question you have to choose pick a
line as one woman to another if she was
you know next door I'd knock on the door
and be like listen honey come here
sweetheart stop saying that in public
because that it's embarrassing that
you're blaming oh another thing they do
the size on anyone else maybe blame it
on your jeans maybe blame it on your
diet but blaming it on a bunch of white
people that did [ __ ] 80 years ago
you're really sounding like an [ __ ]
think about the names that they call
black people when they don't agree with
their agenda like any black
conservatives they go after them with
racial slurs black black white
supremacists as a is my favorite yeah
that's that's that's the best one
and skinny shaming are the same actually
no they're not people are denied jobs
proper Medical Care Health Insurance the
paid
they don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created foreign
if you're like the one percent minority
yeah it's a little harder to get [ __ ]
close if you have 20 size foot feet
might be a little bit harder yeah
store you got to go to the extra store
yeah retards like that is literally
rooted skinny shaming and and this is
back when I was young and I actually
I've actually when when things affected
me that other people said I'm old enough
now an antibiotic I was so skinny when I
was a little girl I don't know how many
of these stories I told you like yeah
you remember one time in the supermarket
I was like you know 20 feet behind my
mother just looking at stuff and some
old lady came up to me and she said
excuse me little girl exactly I remember
she called me little girl excuse me
little girl does your mommy feed you you
gotta speak into them she said excuse me
little girl does your mommy feed you and
I was like yeah she feeds me of course I
was just scrawny scrawny and then
um I got pulled into uh the school
counselor's office once in like the
second or third grade and they asked me
if everything was okay at home because I
was so skinny and like my father was a
butcher when I was a little girl like we
steak every night life was good I never
there's snack drawer was always full I
was blessed I was blessed with that you
were eating enough too
well I had a super fast metabolism
so I was so scrawny and the kids in
school the boys especially were like
excuse me look like Skeletor and they
just made fun of me in front of me and
then when I ran into them in high school
they were like shut up you know like I
looked normal and I looked good then and
they were they were happy with how I
looked but you know it was hard on me as
a kid growing up to be made fun of
growing up get over it and [ __ ] so the
people who were like oh that's not as
bad as fashion I mean yeah it is it's
met and by fat shaming I mean little
kids calling each other fat it's mean
[ __ ] but for this girl to be going on
about how fat people don't get treated
the same in jobs and traveling clothes
and everything like let it [ __ ] go
let it go it was created for and based
around white men like fat phobia is
literally rooted in anti-blackness it's
rooted in racism
no they're not fat people are denied
jobs proper Medical Care Health
Insurance they're paid less they don't
have equal access to clothing travel
many public spaces even the body mass
index the way that it just eliminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like fat phobia is literally
rooted in antibiot Airplane seats well
it's not fair for the skinny person to
have to sit next to have half a seat
that they paid for because your fat ass
takes up three seats rooted in racism
and sexism skinny shaming is not how
many times have you seen marketing
campaigns that are labeled get fat quick
finally add those stubborn 30 pounds
show me where all the weight gain
Industries are show me all the damaging
message you dumb [ __ ] because there are
so many more fat people than skinny
people it's about economics there's a
market there Jesus Christ that's not say
that skinny equals unworthy life or
skinny equals ugly when is the last time
that you've been penalized financially
when an aircraft seed had to be
accommodated to your smaller body when
is the last time you've walked into a
doctor's office and after they weighed
you stop listening to what you were
actually there for and told you to just
gain weight in airplanes you know what
I've done in the past because I was so
skinny when I was young I actually this
is [ __ ] up but I would sit down if I
was on the bus or train or plane where
in Iowa where there was open seating
next to me and I would take out tissues
and I would
I would sit and pretend to cough so that
people didn't sit next to me because I
was a Target because the fat people saw
me and they thought oh good I can have
half of her seat yeah that's one lesson
so you know what pumpkin we all got
problems fix everything fat people
endure all of that and more skinny
people do not face employment
discrimination or medical discrimination
the world was designed for you eat a
burger is just not comparable to
systemic abuse and oppression
I mean she's absolutely right you know
fat shaming and skinny shaming are not
the same because if you're shaming
somebody for being skinny then you're
shaming them for a healthy physique
provided that they aren't you know real
thin if you're shaving them for being
fat you're shaming them for being in an
unhealthy and destructive physical state
you really shouldn't be walking up to
people and shaming them for their
appearance in either case but it is
without question worse to shame a good
thing than it is to shame a Bad Thing
imma be real with y'all I am really sick
and tired of skinny it's coming on this
app and trying to compare fat phobia to
getting called a door once that's called
body shaming and it literally happens to
every single person on the planet at
least once I agree it's not a systemic
issue girl I went to my doctor when I
got diagnosed with severe depression and
she dead ass looked at me and said lose
some weight and break up with your
boyfriend the best advice you could have
gotten if you're with a bad boyfriend
get rid of that relationship will
automatically make you healthier make
you happier and lose some weight who
isn't happier with the healthier body
like everyone knows the saying healthier
body healthier mind so why wouldn't you
listen to them being fat is not good for
you I don't know where when did this
become a when did this become a thing
where people think that being fat is
good for you I I'm genuinely confused I
was in school today thinking about where
I wanted to go for off-campus lunch and
I started looking up restaurant menus
and realized that I didn't want to
linger on the tab too long in case
somebody looked over the fat girl's
laptop seeing where she wanted to go for
lunch and judging me for it I can't walk
into a 7-Eleven and order a Slurpee and
some you're mad that people are judging
you without even saying anything these
these women Mom they're they're losing
it they're losing it what is this she's
mad that she was sitting in a class and
that she doesn't want to look at a food
menu for too long because if people will
look at her and judge her like you're
just gonna be afraid of literally
everything you do because people might
think something about it that's the real
problem that takes us down to the real
problem listen I haven't it's done
broads because I'm afraid that when I
put them down on the counter like a
skinny person could do with no problem
somebody's gonna judge me for it I
decided to a job at a restaurant and
heard somebody say oh they're not gonna
hire me because they think I'm fat
enough to eat all the food they're not
hiring you because if you're fat you
bring in less customers and you don't
make the business as much money there's
a reason that businesses for the most
part would you not rather all beautiful
waitresses than all fat waitresses about
that it depends on the restaurant right
you might be right because you've worked
in restaurants that have no beautiful
waitresses but I'm saying what's better
the chicken franchise or the oh if
you're asking for food or the chicken
parm I'm asking a fat waiter taking his
advice you want the fat guy cooking the
food I could say that y'all got insulted
once and ran with it I feel so bad this
is what people that think this much
about what other people think of them I
mean we should all to some extent take
other people into consideration we don't
want to hurt people if we particularly
respect somebody I think we should work
to um be respectful and be our best
version in front of them without being
fake I would absolutely absolutely judge
you if you were buying a Slurpee and
Skittles at the same time I mean fat or
skinny if I see someone washing down
Skittles with a Slurpee yes I'm gonna
make some judgments about that person
that's disgusting and you would deserve
to be judged for it absolutely you
deserve judgment in fact if someone
walked up to you to your face and made
fun of you for buying Slurpees and scale
at the same time you would deserve that
it would be good it'd be a wake-up call
for you it's like an intervention guess
what you don't get to be free of the
world's judgment here's the news flash
for everybody watching right now you
don't get to be free of the world's
judgment you don't nobody does you are
being judged all the time all the time
people look at us and observe our
behavior and make judgments that [ __ ]
sometimes the judgments are bad
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
neutral this is just what it means to
live in a society among other rational
creatures you can accept that and move
on with your life or you can sit around
crying about I'm being judged stop being
judged yes you are okay we've
established that live your life now or
just stay huddled in a corner in the
fetal position stop judging me in the
fetal position alone where nobody know
where they were that's fine too shut up
with your complaints like victimhood is
the New Black
is so good
trust me I'm not mentally yeah